When I think about
places at Harvard that
are meaningful to me, the
one that first comes to mind
is Memorial Hall.
And it has three
different parts that
are meaningful to me in
somewhat different ways.
The one that is so
powerful in my mind
is the Transept as you
enter into Memorial Hall
where the names of Harvard Union
dead are honored on the walls.
There 136 of those
names and each of them
comes with a date of death.
And most of them have
the name of the battle,
the final battle at which
the individual was killed.
And it includes such individuals
as Robert Gould Shaw, who
commanded the Massachusetts
54th Regiment of Black Troops
at Fort Wagner and died
charging the enemy there
and was buried with his men.
Wilder Dwight, who was killed
in Antietam in the fall of 1862
and wrote a letter to his
mother from the battlefield
on the morning of the battle
saying how cheerful he was
on that misty, moisty morning.
And another, Nathaniel
Bowditch, whose papers
I've read extensively
at the Mass Historical
and I've written
about, who was killed
in Virginia early in
1863 and left wounded
on the battlefield, inspiring
his father, a Harvard Medical
School professor, to devote
himself to ambulances
and making sure ambulances
were provided for the military
so that other men's sons
would not die as his did.
It's a space that
mimics a cathedral
and is meant to
inspire and uplift.
And for me, it certainly does.